tonight on Kitchen Nightmares Chef
Ramsay heads to the prohibition Grill in
Everett Washington
you're all kidding me where he meets an
owner making all the wrong moves belly
dance that was a belly flop Rishi Brown
went from belly dancer to restaurant
owner I thought fresh means that it's
not frozen
and her lack of experience I know
anything about what goes on back there
is evident everywhere oh my gosh the
meat's cooked and Raw on the same shelf
she's oblivious to what is happening in
her kitchen Ray she is a little bit
naive she just started trust Rocky as
her lazy Chef Cooks up one disaster when
was that coats after another
it's sour but in spite of all the
obvious shortcomings I can't help you
one minute longer this owner remains in
denial I think the food is great here
what it's one of the most frustrating
situations ever on Kitchen Nightmares is
anyone [__] real hero is this a joke
this owner may have asked for Chef
Ramsay's help I can't sit here and take
this [__] any longer but doesn't seem
too interested in taking it
foreign
[Music]
Everett Washington 25 miles north of
Seattle this blue-collar town is home to
the prohibition grill a southern
restaurant opened in 2008 by
professional belly dancer Rishi Brown
how are my lips
[Music]
I had no restaurant experience at all
but I felt like if I could run a
successful Dance Company all of these
years surely I could operate a
restaurant business can I get anything
for you Molly no
you good yeah okay because I have no
experience I don't run my kitchen at all
two tops medium medium and rare I hired
someone who's had 30 years of restaurant
experience good job Rock not my first
trip to the rodeo
he's amazing at his job
he's a little bit lazy you're right back
going
he likes to smoke
he likes to talk on his phone hello you
know if I have an order I have to text
him that there's an order
how's it tasting over here it's really
Bland we have customers that complain
all the time
is it okay I've had dishes where I've
smelled it and I was just like you've
got to be kidding me Rocky the ribs were
disgusting if we could fix it we would
but Rocky keeps Rishi in the dark a
little bit what was the problem with the
trout there's no problem with the trout
all right oh my God Rishi is a little
bit naive she just sort of trusts Rocky
he has all the skills and all the
knowledge
yum I don't know anything about what
goes on back there for Rishi to step in
from belly dancing into Running a
Restaurant I don't want to use the word
clueless but she was because she had no
idea
some things that she does that I don't
think a restaurant owner should do
yeah for instance Philly dancing
it doesn't go with the theme of our
restaurant it makes no sense
customers think it's weird
you know I've been in the business 20
years I know how a business is supposed
to be run and this is not the way
we got to get more people in here
unbelievable if prohibition Grill fails
I lose everything I'm really discouraged
I really need help because I'm at a
complete loss to understand what's
happened and I'm not stupid but I really
don't know what's going on
[Music]
oh
wow here he comes
it's like something given in Vegas we've
learned to Buddy dance what the hell has
that got to do with the Russians
am I coming for lunch or are we having a
i i i belly dance do the owners know
this goes on yeah absolutely I am the
owner oh you are the owner yes how long
have you been doing this 30 years and
then you bought a restaurant yes and you
still belly dance yes it's really fun
yeah wow it's about undulating and
shimming right rolling the body in
motion with vibration
[Music]
that's right wow okay
uh
jeez
so how do you go from belly dancing to
becoming a Russian tour well I decided
over
um were you inebriated at the time did
it sort of make your minds a little
light-headed yeah I remember it well but
then once it happened the idea came in
there it was at stake do you ever watch
an erection before or um I worked as a
server for about six months one time
when I was in college wow right yeah
um and style of food what is that we do
a gourmet Southern menu here fine guy we
kind of have a steakhouse theme here
going on Dinner House theme Dinner House
steakhouse yeah fine dining yes some
Southern Flair to it wow
um okay in your mind what's the biggest
problem in my mind
um well we don't have a grill here so we
don't have a grill here
prohibition grill right wow a
Prohibition grill with no Grill wow okay
let me take a seat sure I have a special
seat right back here for you okay grace
uh nice boots by the way oh thank you
I really believe in what we've done here
and I'm sure that Chef Ramsay is going
to love the food today
um have you just been to a party or no I
just got all dressed up just for you
today obviously you just you don't dress
like that normally no I do dress like
this no oh you do dress yeah normally
yeah wow uh so I'm not special anywhere
never mind um actually you are yeah
because this is a special occasion for
sure
I got a little more dolled up but this
is my normal get up okay right
um it's a big menu huh yeah wow
prohibition Grill Southern Cuisine yes
chef Rocky strives originality and
diversity focusing on the quality of
freshness and without a grill that's
quite a statement oh it's so true okay
um how do you rate the food what'd you
give your food out of 10. I give our
food a 10. I think it's yeah I think
it's amazing I love everything on the
menu okay great nice to meet you nice to
meet you two Chef Ramsey thanks for
coming and enjoy your lunch today okay
thank you
what a bizarre dress sense from the
owner I mean she looks like she's in a
fancy dress Britney Spears concert party
[Music]
hello hello I am Candace how are you
yeah bro very nice to meet you oh it's
good to see you too so did Rishi get a
chance to go over the menu at all with
you um briefly
um there's a lot of shall we um what's
the soup of the day the soup of the day
is jalapeno corn chowder what was it
yesterday jalapeno corn chowder all
right so super for two days
last week
so super the week it's
super okay
um let's go for the Cruella how would
you like that prepared
um medium rare please medium rare let's
go for the collard greens as well the
sides the balcony brown sugar glazed
salmon and you know what throw me in a
portion of the pan-fried oysters okay
we'll get that started for you thanks
thank you thank you
[Music]
if oysters so why don't I start with a
cup of soup okay dokie yeah
foreign I was just seeing what you
ordered I thought those were really
great choices our oysters are wonderful
here and my chef always makes the best
soups
can I just let you into a little secret
sure not in front of your customers can
I whisper
yeah
it's the same soup it was on two weeks
ago
super day it means a daily changing soup
I didn't even know what this before the
day meant
[Music]
I thought that just meant what soup we
were serving that day wow
yeah that was lame
soup
of the day a new soup every day okay I'm
going to talk to him about that
wow
I didn't realize that soup of the day
meant a fresh soup every day yeah I
thought soup of the day meant what is
our Soup for the day oh my God I'm not
that stupid it's just that's what I
understood that meant
Candace please
Chef friendly here's our soup thank you
thank you
wow super the week
that's just slop horrible nasty Loop
some sort of dust thing around the
outside of the plate
did you have a chance to taste the soup
yeah I had a chance yeah okay uh yeah
just not nice gnarly should I just get
that out of here uh yes please okay when
was last time you tasted it
um I haven't tasted it you didn't have
this soup I haven't had this soup
wow
Rocky we've had the same soup for seven
days made it Saturday but we wrapped it
and stored it properly
[Music]
okay I'm gonna tell you what the oysters
are going to be fresh and delicious made
right now for you
you mean opened you don't make an oyster
you just open them
huh
oysters are opened
oh got it no he's not opening them daily
oh so he's opening the oysters and no
he's buying them pre-opened how many
bought I think they came in today we
just check yes
Rocky yes when were the oysters
delivered they were delivered here
Friday
they were delivered Friday
right yes so the fresh oysters aren't
exactly fresh but they're from five days
ago five days ago
but we don't get them here Frozen that's
good to know Frozen oysters in Seattle
that would be bad
right
[Music]
so far nothing is quite as it seems
okay so these are the oysters Okay Hand
fried oyster roofs thank you you're
welcome
[Music]
slightly salty creamy delicious
these are just tasteless so he's managed
to take a delicious tasting oyster and
turned into something that's cake and
cornmeal and taste of nothing
how are the oysters yeah they're Bland
they just Taste of nothing I mean let's
have a little just a little just a small
touch I don't eat our oysters oh you
don't eat them I don't eat them here
they're not fresh so I only like fresh
oysters me too yeah wow okay I'm not
gonna try those oysters they think that
they're gross they know better I'm not
trying
um he absolutely hated this he thought
they were gross they're way too much
cornmeal Bland had absolutely no flavor
interesting
Chef Ramsay is in the middle of sampling
prohibition's menu they're Bland they
just Taste of nothing okay and he's
already discovered a lack of freshness a
lack of flavor and a real lack of basic
restaurant knowledge by the owner I
wouldn't try the oysters because they're
not fresh well I thought fresh means
that it's not frozen usually it means
like fresh
fresh from the
you know that sort of thing so I'm like
like soup of the day yeah
okay well let's try this okay this is a
filet mignon filet mignon this is the
collard greens collard greens and it's
wrapped in bacon right wrapped in bacon
yes thank you you're welcome
make this Dreadful absolutely Dreadful
it's got a horrible taint to it well how
did we do on this yeah you're not very
good horrible grayness to it I don't
know what he's done it's almost like the
meat's been boiled nose there collard
greens with just mush may I take it out
of your way and thank you
10 out of 10 so far I'm zero out of ten
let me tell you
these are really mushy
oh yeah really she's like oh I'll be the
judge of that
that's ridiculous those are incredibly
wonderful they are they are a little
mushy they're a little mushy that is the
only problem but the flavor profile is
perfection and the flu he thinks that
it's been boiled boiled I think it's
good do you like it I know it's perfect
I know it is
so here we actually have the salmon
bloody hell
that's the salmon
why does the salmon go in a pinwheel I
don't I don't know thank you
I mean honestly look at that plate I
mean little balls of hush puppies
massive wedge of cornbread that looks
like a door opener and a pinwheel and
fits perfectly you know on the side of
my tomato wow
[Music]
that is [__] disgusting pinwheel yeah
I feel like doing a cartwheel out of
here
oh [__] you know oh he's banging his
hands on his head
that's really bad is he allergic to salt
no there's no seasoning on there
whatsoever aged Balsam and vinegar
macerated with brown sugar on salmon
needs to be backed up with salt
shall I take it away please yeah thank
you you're welcome holy crap
okay he did not like that he thinks that
the balsamic the reduction needs to be
backed up with salt
he wants to know the idea between the
pinwheel of the salmon he doesn't
understand it I think it's interesting I
like it I think it's a I think it's a
cool presentation on the plate I like it
okay way to stand up for your food Rich
way to stand up for your food you do I
like that that's one of my favorite
things on our menu is that presentation
salmon what can you do
[Music]
oh [__] here he comes
introduce me to the team
this is Jeff Jeff hi
Dennis Dennis yep and this is Rocky
right I feel like I've just gone 12
rounds with you let me tell you
let me read you something prohibition
Grill Southern Cuisine Chef Rocky
strives for equality
and freshness correct
freshness
the soup from last week that was called
soup of the day gloopy under Seasons it
wasn't even hot it was just hideous big
fan of that too big fan of the soup what
I've just eaten has been an
embarrassment
pan-fried oysters just solid cornmeal
with no seasoning
it needs some form of seasoning I didn't
know that you don't even know what soup
of the day is
I told you about the pinwheel of salmon
can you go and get me a pinwheel yes
hurry up please
Chef Ramsay I like the pinwheel I'm not
asking you like it you give your food 10
out of 10. so me talking to you about
food it's like yeah I'm talking to a
brick wall behind you right I liked it I
thought it looked nice and kind of
unique and different
kind of unique and different yeah
and how many strips did you get out of a
salmon 14. like until I just looked at
it I didn't even think this was so small
right and even the bloodlines on there
as well nasty Chef to Chef have you any
idea how bad that makes you look
on decisions about how food is prepared
I believe in what they do back there
that's their thing especially Rocky come
on
color greens overcooked tasteless mush I
thought they tasted great yeah they were
overcooked though you knew they were
overcooked I have any idea how [__]
deluded you sound what how can something
be [__] delicious and overcooked
there such thing man ah our customers
that stupid
are you no are you no are you
and you are
yes sir
why did you ask me here if your food's
ten
[Music]
well I was hoping that you could come
here and help me get this business to
the next level because I can't seem to
do that on my own right now how bad is
your business currently how much money
per week are you losing
at least
at least two thousand dollars that's
eight thousand dollars a month that's a
hundred grand a year does that not sink
in anyone's [__] mind
I don't know what to say I like the food
I think the food is great here
after only a short time in the
restaurant Chef Ramsay is shocked by how
lazy Chef Rocky is and how clueless
Reese she is can you get me some
lipstick and before dinner service there
is one issue he wants to take care of
right away prohibition Grill
my ass
no more false advertising he's putting
tape over the grill
excellent
I got a crab cake going out with a
Caesar and small salad where's Rishi by
the way she's getting ready for belly
dancing tonight
we're ready to go on the second check as
well Candace you're up
where was this
what cornbread
oh when was this cornbread made that was
made the other day and we weren't even
going to serve it we just threw it back
here because we weren't even going to
serve it
you just threw it oh Dennis Dennis
Dennis big deep breath you just made it
made it the other day yeah threw it back
here because you weren't serving it
because yeah yeah it got burnt and Rocky
told me just go throw it in the back
room for right now
I just feel that oh I know it's terrible
I don't know it's pretty bad music music
music music
you all kidding me five six seven and
foreign
[Music]
world and she thinks that everybody's
loving it and as you look around you can
tell that people are confused
[Music]
mortified
Chef Ramsay locked himself in the
freezer to get away from the belly
dancing
[Applause]
oh my gosh
foreign
that was a belly flop
following the impromptu belly dance
kitchen please so this is pretty much
rare and they wanted a medium steak
there's a steady stream of undercooked
dishes coming back to the kitchen back
in the oven please no no no Colleen
they're supposed to be medium oh oh no
come on what is this Rocky could you put
these steaks on just a tiny bit more all
right guys this is just in the last five
minutes I don't know what's going on but
you know can someone get a grip please
another medium refire this is normal all
these complaints with temperatures on
the meats especially on the steaks is
that accept all to you yeah
people hate our food so far so good this
evening and she turned to Blind deer
which frustrates us all
you know why does Rishi walk around like
everything's just perfect and a big
smile on the place that's what she
believes it all is what's wrong Danny
what's wrong the ravioli is cold wow wow
wow yeah the kitchen needs help loss is
everything tasting good
yeah
right in the bottom of the pot okay
thanks for your comments
um I just want to let you know this
table right here they both think that
the gravy tastes like it came out of the
bottom of the pan they're really unhappy
about that should I just go ahead and
take that back to the kitchen then show
restrooms which type of ways let's go
with it now okay my apologies Madam if
you're not happy with it I'd rather you
didn't eat it the sauce tastes like
liver very far a fresh chicken for lady
with no sauce sorry about that we'll get
that going for you can you taste the
gravy I'm gonna taste it yeah
the gravy tastes really gritty to me now
I see right here Jeff can you pass me
that gravy everyone's complaining about
the gravy and they think it tastes like
liver because it's really gritty oh is
it nice River's made last week and
Frozen last week in Frozen
[Music]
oh
my God
it's sour
all of you get any plate of gravy off
the table now
[Music]
oh my gosh look at that drives anything
with the meats cooked and Raw on the
same Shelf
Rocky you got the ribs there what's next
to the ribs raw pork raw pork get Richie
please Rishi rule number one crosstalk
examination explain to Rishi never saw a
cook fried next to a raw product so just
look at that what is that there raw
product raw pork what's that there
cooked ribs cooked ribs and this here
what is this guys oh my God it's trout
what is neutral old trout just feel how
sticky that is on top that's the old
trout and that there
is the fresh one underneath right very
important now you pull today
what is that
bread pudding red pudding red what oh my
God
oh my God Rocky come on when was that
cooked Saturday what day is it today
and what we didn't sell on Saturday what
do you think should happen it's
fantastic oh my gosh
stop ladies and gentlemen I'm sorry I am
so disappointed but whatever you're
eating now just stop stop
[Music]
dinner service at the prohibition Grill
has just gone from plain bad boy is that
there raw product what's that there
cooked ribs it's a downright dangerous
ladies and gentlemen
whatever you're eating now just stop and
Chef Ramsay has had enough I am not
gonna stand here and watch this kitchen
send you food that is a
cross-contaminated b reheated from
Frozen it's a absolute embarrassment
yeah obviously not serving anything else
there won't be any more food coming to
the table tonight we're really sorry
about this experience we had a lot of
really unsatisfied unhappy guests
tonight and that hurts
icon help you one minute longer do you
know why why because you madam cannot
help yourself lazy Chef okay well this
is the deal
first of all I've known about Rocky
being lazy for a really long time I've
called him out on it a thousand times
and you know what I get this is what you
get for how much you pay me I don't make
enough this is you know not entirely
accurate well what it is accurate like
he and I go around once a year about
this exact thing because he doesn't make
the money that he wants to make I like
him so much in so many ways and so many
things that he does but he's not held to
the same standard that everybody else
has held to Here by me because what am I
going to do I don't know how to come in
here I don't know how to [__] train
anybody else I don't know how to Butch
the meats I don't know
losing a ship yes that doesn't care yes
that's ruining your business there's
some things Rocky is doing good and
every single time because I I can't
[__] sit here and take this [__] any
longer
ah
I am not going to listen
to excuses you keep on telling me that
he's good and he's well because he's
been here with me all these four years
and my feeling is is that he has the the
skills to do it why are you convinced
that he has the skills to do it because
I don't know about that job and he's
been here since day one and he has led
me to believe because he's led me to
believe he has he has and intuitively
I've known it he's allowed him to take
you hostage I have so you deserve what
you get there because you're not
prepared to step up no I stepped up I
fired him two months ago he was gone for
a week in the kitchen they didn't know
how to do the order they just didn't
know and then I brought him back again I
actually feel safe for you do you know
why you're being used
step up yeah get a grip yeah because
time right now is not your friend
I'm done for tonight
[Music]
Chef Ramsay thinks he's
unbelievably lazy
has got me over a barrel and the fact
that I allow him
to be the kind of Chef that he is here
is unacceptable
well and he's gotten away with it for so
long like
how is he going to change his behavior
after this long
[Music]
after shutting down the restaurant hello
ladies let's have a we'll see overhead
Chef Ramsay is completely bewildered
he's looking for some explanation and he
begins the day with Rishi and her staff
let's be honest last night was a
disaster
everyone agreed yeah absolutely and
customers absolutely at the Wit's End I
mean there was one table in the front
there that had their dish free fired
three times
when was the last time that happened I'd
say it happened all the time yeah yeah
honestly Candice absolutely what is the
response from the chef he usually takes
it really personal and thinks that
they're wrong and he's right and food
taste was fine what does that tell you
it's Rocky he and I started here at the
same time and he was very passionate in
the last two years 30 maybe wow uh last
time I worked got 15 orders he goes
outside behind the building 15 orders
and your head chef is outside smoking
and I just don't feel like going outside
to get them so I text him do you think
it's right that he should be outside and
you have to text him to come in oh God
no no and we have to supplement Rocky's
income by tipping well enough is a week
we have about three percent three
percent of the food sales the head chef
getting tips he told me that that's what
other people do in other restaurants and
that's fair they put the food out to
give the server the opportunity to earn
the tips
we've told her though that's not how it
is in the industry no it's not he's made
me feel this way over time that I owe
him why'd you owe him because I'm afraid
that I can't make this happen without
him because
because I just I feel like I don't have
the experience to know what to do if I
don't have someone so you think he's not
replaceable right so how many people
feel that this restaurant would be
better off without Rocky
why'd you support
Rocky the way you're doing I'm just
scared to take that chance Richard this
is crazy
I don't know why I'm like that I'm not
like that in any other places in my life
crazy my darling
vulnerable situation and be beholden to
a chef that's tearing you apart
[Music]
Rishi is completely afraid of change
she doesn't like to change her hair she
doesn't like to change her house she
doesn't like to change anything tomorrow
if I just talk to Rishi alone please
[Music]
I'm just scared because I
because when I when I did this I really
didn't know when I was getting myself
into and then last night when you just
stood up and you told Rocky this is stop
making excuses this is wrong you're lazy
I just have been so scared to do that I
appreciate your honesty I can really
feel especially today that you care but
when I first arrived you were almost
tiptoeing over the issues as opposed to
tackling them head on you know
just even if he steps up right now who's
to say what's gonna happen
can't even tell you
why let them
I don't want to I'm just so scared
[Music]
oh me I'm here
I'm here okay
come on
I'm here I'm gonna get this thing sorted
I was too scared to make that decision
with Rocky and not have any
anyone there that could say okay well
let's do this okay no I need to find
someone else but I'm just afraid that
there's not going to be somebody else's
that because he has me believing that
like
I don't pay enough to have
I really listen to me and listen very
carefully I will do all I can
to find you a chef
this is your decision your business your
future
your money
you need to take responsibility I can't
do that for you okay I know it has to be
that why would I want to go forward with
someone who's sabotaging my business
don't worry okay thank you
I'll see you surely I'll get on the
phone stand strong yeah okay
that's the right thing to do
to let Rocky go
after a heart to heart with Chef Ramsay
Rishi now finally understands what is
the main problem of the restaurant oh
rich Okay so
I'm gonna fire Rocky today because Chef
Ramsay's gonna help me find someone
became very clear to me that Rocky's not
going to change even if he says he's
going to step up and blah blah he's not
going to change
it's your business it's your livelihood
it's it's your life
so now what
[Music]
oh [__]
hello
[Music]
what's going on
going out the door
oh
ah man
Okay so
I don't wanna I don't wanna beat around
the bush about it unfortunately I'm
letting you go
it just things haven't changed even
after our last reconciliation things
still haven't changed
I'm sorry
yeah I
I understand
you know I've gotten complacent and I
realized that and uh
sorry I had to come to this I'm sorry
I'm so related to know that I don't have
to feel like I'm held hostage anymore I
have the courage now to make the changes
necessary
[Music]
you know it went really well Rocky took
responsibility for what happened he
didn't try to make me feel like it was
my fault or right or anything I felt
like a boss I felt empowered I felt like
because I'm making the right decision
and I'm going to make it right now yeah
let's get the rest of the staff okay you
and I are gonna have a little fun right
team I want all of you just go in the
kitchen let's go
okay do you have any trousers or jeans
or no that's it that's it wow
like a Naked Chef
was the last time you actually cooked a
dish in here
never you've never cooked in here ever
ever wow you should never ever be
intimidated by the kitchen
right with Rocky I never felt invited to
come into my kitchen I felt like that
was his place and my place was my job
nothing to worry about whatsoever to be
really honest please I love to cook
seriously seriously that is good to know
you know that why didn't you tell me
that yesterday
right first on slow cooked duck salad a
little touch of olive oil
Just a Touch we've got some fresh herbs
frize salad now your turn take your
spoon and just bake over the duck legs
please tilt the pan and baste nice there
we are doesn't look great in the kitchen
by the way
good there you go how's that now
way better good hold the bone sit there
nice perfect
wow thank you she just cooked those
dishes there with me like a boss like an
owner that's what you've got to do when
you've taken the responsibility of
opening a restaurant it's about having a
presence right and we're able to get a
knife and form them and sit down with a
bite to eat it's amazing how just being
in the kitchen with Chef Ramsay I felt
really empowered now this is a tent
[Music]
I am not going to be afraid anymore I
love it
after a great deal of research Chef
Ramsay and his team work through the
night to transform the restaurant from a
southern style Grill into a gastropub
[Music]
foreign
now I have some very very exciting
changes to show you
right take off your blindfolds
[Music]
[Applause]
so awesome progression Grill is no
longer a grill welcome to your new
Gastro Pub
we've brought out the texture of those
amazing bricks the Chevrons give it that
modern feel look at the bar we've
brightened up the whole room with that
beautiful red lacquered bar I love
I love it it's a good time for a change
I'm so excited right now here in Everett
nobody has a building that looks like
this it's beautiful in here I love it
Rishi yesterday I made you a promise
that I would find you a chef
Chef has cooked for over 20 years in the
Northwest oh God I'll introduce you to
Tyler chef
hello sir let me tell you something
about this young man he is opening up
his very own cool hip amazing restaurant
in downtown Seattle radiator now until
then he's gonna be here with you Rishi
and after he's gone he'll make sure
there's a chef replacing him that is up
to the standard of what both you and
Chef requires excited yeah
yeah now I feel like I have a real
chance for real success I'm so grateful
to have you here
in keeping with the new Gastropub theme
oh my
God
Chef Ramsay has designed a menu that can
be easily executed in rishi's small
kitchen oh my gosh oh Chef Ramsay I'm
I'm so excited cheers I want you all to
dig in have a taste
here you go honey yeah I'm gonna start
over here oh my gosh that was amazing
with the food and the decor now looked
after Chef Ramsay has one more makeover
to reveal
and that is Rishi wow you look amazing
thanks I love it how's my hair look
obviously it's about time rishi's attire
it was still a little bit inappropriate
with Chef Tyler now at the helm new
systems have been implemented yeah and
I'm right on top good and that includes
Rishi taking a lead role as expediter
when I fire entrees I take it stick them
here perfect fire left one place that's
one heard
spread the word about the new
prohibition Chef Ramsay invited
influential bloggers
in charge of her restaurant put your
right hand up
yes
I do solemnly swear I do solemnly swear
that I will no longer be hosting belly
dancers I will no longer be hosting
belly dancers thank you you're welcome
thank you
the knowledge that he's given me to
empower me to be a real restaurant owner
I've never had that
this has to be one of the most unusual
Kitchen Nightmares ever Rishi had no
idea that her loyalty towards Rocky was
actually ruining her business thankfully
she saw the light stepped up and made a
very very brave decision
more importantly she now understands the
key ingredients to running a successful
dining room
belly dancing is not one of them
soul food belly dancing in the north
west wow
[Music]
in the weeks that followed the one and
only Gastropub in Everett Washington is
a hit
and for the first time since she opened
all right and the salmon for you my dear
Rishi truly feels she is in control of
her very own restaurant I'm so excited
that Everett has a restaurant like this
I know
[Music]